bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur tv fil 78 pour un nouveau numéro du
7 8 sociétés
le débat de ce soir frappe sur l'un
d'eux porte pardon sur la crise agricole
qui frappe le pays
de nombreuses manifestations ont eu lieu
cette année pour marquer la colère des
producteurs de lait de céréaliers ou
d'éleveurs mais de quelle agriculture
par le ton s toute l'agriculture
française qui est en difficulté
ou est ce le productivisme qui est en
cause comment en est on arrivé là
quelles sont les alternatives locales
qui existe dans les yvelines sont elles
assez efficace pour se veut pour
subvenir aux besoins de tous n'hésitez
pas à réagir sur le twitter de
l'émission en tapant hashtag 7,8 société
pour répondre à ces questions deux
invités autour de la table luc miserait
d'abord du parti communiste français des
yvelines vous mettez notamment
régulièrement place des points de vente
directe entre producteurs et
consommateurs et vous êtes chargé des
questions sur l'économie sociale et
solidaire dans ce pc f60 18 bonsoir
bonsoir
nous recevons également dorian ce pack
qui est coordinateur général de
l'association terre et cités on soirs
comme ça alors l'objectif de terry cité
s'est pérennisé promouvoir et développer
une agriculture de qualité sur le
plateau de saclay ses valets de
préserver et mettre en valeur le
patrimoine associés est ce que c'est
bien ça fait alors nous aurions dû avoir
quatre invités autour de la table avec
deux agriculteurs de la région
mais avec les récentes intempéries sont
retenus sur leurs champs donc ce sont
des aléas du direct
on va commencer messieurs si vous voulez
bien avec un extrait c'est françois
lecoq président de la fdsea sur le
canton de houdan qui étaient intervenus
dans le journal du 2 septembre sur tv
fil pour expliquer les raisons de la
mobilisation des agriculteurs
on écoute et ensuite je vais vous
demander vos réactions bien sûr on
écoute françois lecoq le fond une
revendication qu'il est simple
aujourd'hui
les céréaliers qui n en soutien à nos
amis éleveurs nous avons besoin de
l'élevage
aujourd'hui l'élevage va mal en france
comme la grande culture du fait de trop
de normes et trop de réglementation on a
aujourd'hui des politiques français qui
ont complètement oublié que
l'agriculture est une activité
économique et qu'il nous faut être
concurrentiel qui nous ne tiendrons pas
fait dix ans qu'on leur répète ce n'est
pas la défaite de françois hollande il
faut et tonnay bon content que ça dure
et qu'on empile des réglementations sans
en retirer
et aujourd'hui l'agriculture est en
difficulté mais beaucoup d'entreprises
autres que l'agriculture subi les mêmes
problèmes de l'ordre et n'a pu être
compliqué les demi frères une réaction
sur les propos de françois lecoq trop de
réglementations sur l'agriculture ça
c'est un discours qu'on entend
régulièrement et pas simplement dans
l'agriculture donc qu'ils aient
simplification avoir sans doute mais en
général quand il ya des réglementations
qui se développe c'est aussi quand même
très souvent parce qu'il ya des origines
et ce dont souffre le plus l'agriculture
à mon avis c'est plus des contraintes
que lui leur impose le crédit agricole
par exemple que leur impose le fait de
ne pas avoir la capacité de développer
leur activité de diversifier leurs
activités
on est dans une région
traditionnellement qui est très
céréalière et puis bon bah je ne peux
pas m'empêcher de penser que
il ya une petite manipulation politique
derrière tout ça laquelle derrière la
fnsea et la fdsea en tout cas la plupart
des fdsea syndicat majoritaire auquel
syndicale majoritaire mais qui est quand
même très largement marqué à droite
donc on utilise ça comme d'autres ont
utilisé le mariage pour tous les
problématiques qui sont réelles y'a rien
à voir entre les problèmes des
céréaliers qui en général se porte très
bien et les problèmes des éleveurs et
leur solidarité
on a confiance en eux selon un bon vieux
proverbe comme dans un âne qui recule
moi je pense que je comprends en fait
d'une certaine manière la détresse et le
sentiment de détresse des exploitants
agricoles parce qu'on a je pense par les
politiques publiques ont été mises en
place au niveau national et au niveau
européen
créer une
une déconnexion d'une certaine manière
entre les agriculteurs et les
territoires dans lesquels ils
s'inscrivent et c'est en fait à la
sortie de la seconde guerre mondiale on
a mis en place la politique agricole
commune il faut savoir qu'à l'époque en
europe de manière générale en
fonctionnaires et tickets de
rationnement que ça a duré un certain
nombre d'années après la guerre et du
coup la priorité à cette époque là
c'était de nourrir l'europe et donc du
coup on s'est donné les moyens de
massivement développer la production
agricole par le biais du développement
du match finisse par le biais du
développement des engrais des pesticides
etc pour augmenter les productivités
arriver à nourrir l'europe
à cette époque là c'était nécessaire
puisque l'europe n'était pas
autosuffisante en termes alimentaire on
avait des gros problèmes d'alimentation
en europe et donc du coup il y avait
effectivement des mesures à prendre
le problème c'est que au moment où le
système a atteint ses objectifs et même
il s'est mis à les dépasser
on n'a pas su revoir les objectifs pour
les adapter aux changements de société
et donc maintenant en gros les
agriculteurs gardent un système des d un
système de soutien par les politiques
publiques qui encourage un certain type
de développement alors que ce même
système est par des systèmes de
quotas etc et donc du coup je comprends
tout à fait qu'il puisse y avoir d un
sentiment un peu de frustration
d'agriculteurs qui sont pris d'une
certaine
d'un certain côté entre un système qui
les encouragent vers une seule et unique
direction qui est sans doute la quête
justement vers les cahiers dirais que je
devienne direction de produire de plus
en plus et serra et d'industrialiser de
plus en plus les exploitations pas
forcément que ce soit toujours négatif
il ya sans doute certaines
configurations dans lesquelles
effectivement il faut pouvoir amplifier
le volume etc
mais le fait que ce soit le modèle
unique qui est proposé c'est sans doute
un petit peu problématique en ile de
france on sait qu'il ya eu un
effondrement un petit peu de toutes les
filières
d'élevage des filières laitières et
c'est avec la mastérisation des points
de collectes etc
c'est de plus en plus difficile
notamment pour les exploitants qui sont
en périurbain je pense que beaucoup des
exploitants qui sont sur notre
territoire aujourd'hui sont des
exploitants qui ont doivent faire face
aux contraintes périurbaines et du coup
il ya sans doute dans ces contextes là à
repenser la manière dont l'agriculture
peut s'inscrire sur nos territoires dans
un contexte qui est assez périurbain et
avec cette ce problème d'effondrement
des filières qui qui est assez complexe
aujourd'hui pour les agriculteurs alors
là on a beaucoup entendu ça de la part
des agriculteurs des éleveurs des
producteurs comment expliquez vous qu'un
producteur qu'un éleveurs puissent
travailler à perte
vendre son ne pas pouvoir fixer sur le
prix de la viande qui il élève du lait
qu'il produit des céréales qu'il plante
comment expliquer ça concrètement
concrètement c'est le fait que les
agriculteurs en fait sont devenus non
plus des artisans qui disons maîtriser
l'ensemble de la valeur ajoutée sur leur
production comme c'était le cas au
sortir de la seconde guerre mondiale je
dis pas qu'il faut revenir à ses modèles
là parce qu'on savait aussi les
difficultés de l'agriculture à cette
époque mais je pense qu'à une réflexion
à mener là dessus sont devenus des
producteurs de manière trop de matière
première pour une bonne partie d'entre
eux est en fait aujourd'hui une bonne
partie de la valeur ajoutée est réalisée
par ceux qui font l'étape d'après c'est
à dire les industries agro alimentaires
etc qui vont transformer après cette
matière première dans les produits qui
sont commercialisés qui s'occupe de la
commercialisation de la valorisation des
produits etc
nous ce qu'on voit sur le plateau de
saclay est ce qu'on encourage c'est
d'encourager les exploitants qui sont
aujourd'hui pour beaucoup effectivement
des exploitants céréaliers puisque c'est
là ce vers quoi on les a encouragés
aujourd'hui à se réapproprier cette
valeur ajoutée ces étapes de
transformation et c'est ce qui amène à
recréer de l'emploi sur les territoires
et à reprendre le contrôle justement sur
cette valeur ajoutée pour vendre
directement les produits aux citoyens
d'autant que la demande est quand même
énorme on est sur un bassin de
population direct avec huit cent mille
habitants on a onze millions d'habitants
dans la
non en région ile de france il ya une
forte demande de produits locaux
auraient été réalisées avec miserait oui
ça ça s'appelle la loi du marché c'est à
dire que à un moment donné nous qu'est
ce qu'on a voulu faire mettre en
relation directement les producteurs
avec les consommateurs qu'on peut
appeler des consomm acteur puisque on
essaye de les rendre conscients de la
démarche qu'ils font et ses producteurs
et bien en squeez ans à la fois les
négociants les intermédiaires et la
grande distribution parce que c'est eux
qui se gavent parce que oui il ya des
transformateurs mais il ya aussi les
négociants les intermédiaires qui font
pas grand chose
la grande distribution qui leur imposent
des prix alors la grande distribution ou
les grands comme billard etc etc qui
leur imposent des prix parce qu'ils sont
capables d'aller sur le marché
et effectivement après on rentre en
concurrence y compris au sein de
l'europe
sans parler de l'amérique latine par
exemple
mais au sein de l'europe avec les
allemands qui font travailler dans leur
ferme des employés agricoles qui paye
avec des lance pierres qui viennent de
pologne où john jones et zou et c'est
donc toute cette déréglementation là et
au détriment des producteurs et des
consommateurs au bout du compte c'est
pour ça que nous on s'est mis en
relation avec un syndicat agricole qui
est lui minoritaire mais qui symbole dhf
le modef c'était dans le mouvement de
défense des exploitants familiaux qui
cherchent à garder une échelle une
agriculture à échelle humaine et tout ça
s'inscrit aussi dans des logiques un
d'aménagement du territoire puisque là
on voit que un peu ce que fait la
société
voilà donc d'aménagement
du territoire mais il n'y a pas de
politique agricole ni dans ce pays né en
europe pour accompagner les agriculteurs
par rapport à ça on laisse tout à la loi
du marché
donc du coup il ya ceux qui résistent
parce que bon ils ont ça et qui sont
aperçus quand même que six ans des
témoins auprès du crédit agricole
mais il arrivait à mieux s'en sortir que
de toujours être dans cette surenchère
d'agrandir etc etc
et puis dans le même temps de produire
quelque chose de qualité qu'on est
capable d'identifier alors qu'est ce qui
entraîna yves indemniserait de ranspach
si des intermédiaires sont les
responsables de cette crise agricole
puis ce qu'ils imposaient les prix
qu'est ce qui empêche les agriculteurs
de couper les ponts avec les
intermédiaires
c'est très compliqué c'est aujourd'hui
le système entier est structurée comme
ça c'est pour ça que nous on dit pas non
plus on ne peut pas
on peut pas changer brutalement les
choses etc
il ya vraiment une réflexion à avoir et
il ya sans doute aussi certaines des
filières qui sont en place on
l'ile-de-france a quand même des
capacités en termes de production de
céréales qui sont excellentes et il ya
des filières qu'ils sont bien en place
et c'est donc pourquoi pas continuer à
utiliser ça mais quand même
en revoyant peut-être un petit peu la
manière dont les agriculteurs sont
positionnés par rapport à ça parce que
même un céréales aujourd'hui il ya une
les exploitants sont extrêmement soumis
à la question des des fluctuations par
exemple de des taux et une année peut
être excellente et l'année d'après peut
être catastrophique et etc et ça c'est
très difficile à vivre pour les
agriculteurs en fait d'être dépendants
traditionnellement ils sont déjà
dépendants du temps de la météo etc
maintenant en plus de ça ils sont
dépendants de comment la météo a été en
russie comment la météo a été aux états
unis et c'est donc du coup nous voilà on
dit en gros le positionnement qu'on a
par rapport à ces questions là c'est de
dire il faut pas forcément remettre en
cause tout le système parce
qu'aujourd'hui on saurait pas faire
autrement directement comme ça il faut
le faire progressivement et peut-être
pas mettre tous ses oeufs dans le même
panier et c'est le choix que font
beaucoup d exploiter en tout cas sur le
plateau de saclay c'est à dire il
conserve une activité en céréales parce
que c'est aussi ce qu'ils savent faire
c'est des métiers différents quand même
à chaque fois qu'on change quand on se
met à faire de la commercialisation
belle et on à apprendre un nouveau
métier et c'est un mot c'est un boulot
donc on peut pas forcément tout faire
tout en même temps conserver ses bases
mais comment va la mettre en place des
diversifications mettre en place
d'autres choses qu'il faut faire que le
jour où les cours de la céréale se
cassent complètement la figure eh ben on
a autre chose replonger 60 sur lequel on
peut se reposer et là du coup on gagne
aussi un peu d'autonomie effectivement
par rapport à des grandes filières très
industrialisé qui peuvent avoir tendance
là je rejoins années de miserey des fois
à serrer un peu la vis sur les
exploitants et à les amener dans des
positions qui sont pas très confortable
de kent moi je dirais les étrangler un
parce que vous pourrez être clair c'est
ça parce que il faut il faut que enfin
les téléspectateurs se rendent bien
compte quand même que
il ya effectivement un réel malaise
profond
les agriculteurs rapporté c'est un
nombre de personnes dans les catégories
socioprofessionnelles qui est pas très
très important mais rapportée en
proportionnalité c'est une des
professions il ya des taux de suicide
des plus importants donc la situation
est très très grave
et en fait on a le problème d'une pac
qui est perverse politique avec dans la
mesure où en fait elle nourrit plus
justement les grands céréaliers que les
petites exploitations alors il ya les
contraintes tout ça oui mais alors de
quel agriculteur par le sna moquant bien
pour terme sur les contraintes des
céréaliers on nous parle de normes etc
etc
dans le même temps qu'il nous parle de
l'état de la nappe phréatique qui est
sous la beauce par exemple parce que si
on met des normes sait aussi qu'à un
moment donné il y avait eu des abus de
kells agriculteurs de quelle agriculture
par le monde
est-ce que c'est toute l'agriculture
française l'agriculture c'est un terme
générique inquiets à seller est-ce que
c'est toute l'agriculture française qui
est en crise ou est ce que c'est juste
les gros producteurs céréaliers les gros
producteurs de lait ou les les grands
producteurs de viande
moi je crois qu'il ya vraiment une crise
assez générale permet à un
positionnement de l'agriculture qui est
pas tellement pour sortir un petit peu
justement des questions vraiment très
technique et des questions très précises
au niveau financière je pense qu'être
derrière une question en termes de
positionnement dans la société il ya 50
ans les agriculteurs c'était vraiment
des acteurs majeurs dans la gestion des
territoires
c'était des gens qui étaient très
intéressés ray très fortement inséré
dans l'institut socio économiques locaux
qui construisaient vraiment au
développement des territoires etc
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs c'est d'une
part
dès maintenant quand même principalement
des acteurs économiques qui sont un
petit peu cantonner à ce rôle de
production alimentaire vers on sait pas
trop où mais voilà il faut produire pour
nourrir le monde ce qui est nécessaire
mais du coup on a un peu l'impression
qu'ils ont perdu le rôle qu'ils avaient
dans le développement des territoires
etc et que du coup ils sont un peu tout
seul face au reste de la société
et ça je pense que c'est une erreur
fondamentale parce que si on perd le
lien avec les agriculteurs
on se retrouve du coup dans des
positions de la société civile
aujourd'hui qui peuvent parfois sur
certains aspects est assez
revendicatrice sans réaliser que les
agriculteurs d'une certaine manière on
fait exactement ce qu'on leur avait
demandé de faire c'est à dire que à la
sortir de la seconde guerre mondiale
avec la mise en place de l'impact sera
vincent a les dents ça donnerait ils ont
fait ça et maintenant on se rend compte
que c'est pas une bonne direction mais
on fait pas tellement bougé les systèmes
qu'on a mis en place et on leur reproche
de faire exactement ce qu'on leur a
demandé de faire au début donc du coup
je comprends qu'ils soient dans une
position quand même assez compliqué à
gérer
il ya sans doute voilà vraiment à revoir
le fond de comment est-ce qu'on peut
accompagner aujourd'hui les évolutions
du monde agricole est aussi c'est pas
seulement quelques questions souhait
qu'une question technique je pense qu' à
revoir aussi la place qu'on donne à ceux
qui produisent l'alimentation qui nous
nourrit dans notre société et plus
simplement les considérer comme les
agriculteurs et les bouseux et etc mais
vraiment leur donner un rôle central
parce que sans eux d'un tabac ne peut
pas manger alors justement le rôle
central qu'elle aurait redonné ce
notamment par des actions citoyennes
actions concrètes pour rapprocher
consommateur et au producteur on dit
souvent que le bio ou le local peut être
plus cher
nous sommes allés demander donc au
saint-quentinoise aux saint quentinois
s'ils étaient prêts à payer plus cher
pour consommer bio et ou locales on
écoute les réponses est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à payer plus cher de manger bio ou
locales je paye déjà plus cher que
manger bio c'est ça contient moins de
pesticides ddt agents nocifs pour la
santé donc voilà déjà le gouvernement
devrait faire quelque chose là dessus on
ne mange que du bio et puis c'est tout
oui je suis prêt je fais des forts de
temps en temps la librairie un marché
bio qui vient des fois le dimanche je
prends moi mais de qualité voilà à deux
c'est possible mais ça a un coût plus
important c'est sûr
donc là moi je peux me permettre parce
que j'en ai très peu dans la famille
maintenant autant locale tant qu'à faire
pourquoi le bio bon le biou c'est
certainement très bien mais est-ce que
c'est vraiment du bio alors est ce que
c'est une alternative crédible est
d'abord de vouloir développer le bio et
le local dans tout le pays
ou est-ce que ça reste utopiste déjà
enfin fait toujours des oppositions il
ya le bio et puis bon il ya entre deux
il ya aussi l'agriculture raisonnée qui
existent aussi
donc voilà le
le bio nous on travaille avec différents
agriculteurs y en a un qui est qui et en
bio is fait engueuler par ses collègues
qui lui disent mais pourquoi tu vends
pas plus cher donc le bio c'est pas fort
c'est à dire beaucoup plus cher pas plus
cher eh ben c'est bien parce que
certains ont utilisé ce créneau là y
compris on va trouver pris à faire venir
du soja de l'autre bout du monde dans la
filière bio etc
donc il ya des dérives aussi là dedans
s'est d'ailleurs dit dans le reportage
que que vous avez utilisé donc il faut
clarifier un petit peu tout ça mais le
développer le bio c'est possible et pas
forcément beaucoup plus cher mais
maintenant ça mais aussi en perspective
notre type de consommation
parce que dans le même temps parfois
c'est plus cher parce qu'à un moment
donné bah oui il faut rémunérer les gens
correctement donc pour qu'ils soient
rémunérés correctement c'est ça peut
être plus cher mais si c'est plus cher
ça veut dire que 1
le problème majeur dans notre société
c'est l'augmentation des salaires
c'est à dire qu'il ya le cac40 qui
explose
mais les salaires ils restent figées
c'est à dire que le pouvoir d'achat des
gens se réduit donc ça c'est une
problématique
et puis ensuite en ce qui concerne le
type de consommation
ben consommer de qualité ça veut dire
aussi peut-être consommer moins mais de
qualité
et ça ça peut être possible pour
certaines personnes
et ça permettrait à mieux rémunérer le
producteur agriculteurs ou l'éleveur de
payer un petit peu plus ou est-ce que
les questions sont complètement délier
mais par exemple sur la pac il pourrait
y avoir quand on dit qu'il faut la
repenser la foule à repenser aussi par
rapport à ça aujourd'hui elle donne plus
aux céréaliers parce que quand même
oui l'ensemble de l'agriculture est
touché enfin les céréaliers quand même
beaucoup moins sur tous les gros
beaucoup moins que les autres 1e ils
sont sûrs sur leurs tablettes ils sont
pas bons donc cet enjeu là on peut aussi
le remettre en perspective sur un
réaménagement un d'une pac qui qu'ils
soient reconsidérées à l'échelle de
notre temps donc mieux redistribuer
l'argent de la relaxe et puis en même
temps quand on parle des aspects de la
fiscalité parce que ça touche aussi ces
aspects là dorian spaf moi je vous
rejoins sur la question que je pense
qu'il ya une grosse problématique est
celle de l'emploi agricole notamment
parce que quand on parle justement de
créer la diversification etc
ça veut dire qu'on crée de l'emploi est
aujourd'hui l'emploi agricole n'est pas
du tout aidé on est de l'agriculture sur
la base et surface on est pas du tout
l'agriculture sur la base des emplois
qu'elle produit là il ya sûrement une
piste qui est au plus le chant est grand
plus on a d'argent va forcément d'argent
si on est tout seul sur sa machine et
c'est en même temps mais ces gains de
productivité sans doute à un moment ils
ont été nécessaires ils ont permis
justement d'arriver l'autonomie
alimentaire de l'europe etc
donc on peut pas remettre les choses à
plat comme ça mais quand même bon juste
sur la question des sérails est
aujourd'hui sur le fait de deux bouts de
pousser de plus en plus l'exploitation à
grandir et c'est ça veut dire qu'ils
sont obligés aussi d'investir sur du
matériel qui est de plus en plus coûteux
voilà c'est je pense pas que ce soit
disant la portion est effectivement la
production agricole qui soit le plus
malmené aujourd'hui moi c'est moi j'en
discutais avec un certain d'entre eux
s'est pas non plus forcément très
confortable à vivre tous les jours parce
qu'à des taux d'emprunt et serra qui
sont très importants pour les mêmes des
machines etc mais bon c'est un peu un
aparté mais effectivement je pense que
il ya sans doute un positionnement à
retrouver où on peut voilà réintégrer la
valeur ajoutée de la vente des produits
dans les circuits de commercialisation
et qu'il est bien des agriculteurs en
bénéficier directement et qu'ils soient
du coup capable à partir de cette valeur
ajoutée et peut-être effectivement à
partir d'une évolution aussi des
politiques publiques en la matière de re
créer l'emploi sur les territoires et de
de rendre les produits qu'ils produisent
directement disponibles à des
populations sans qu'on ait à faire des
circuits de son sport qui sont parfois
un peu un peu aberrant il et pour
terminer sur ces circuits courts ou sur
le bio en général parce que ça peut être
une solution puisque souvent on entend
les grands industriels dire que toute
façon le bio et le local ne seront
jamais suffisant ne seront jamais assez
productif assez efficace pour nourrir
tout le pays
est ce que c'est un faux argument est ce
que c'est vrai je pense pas
qu'aujourd'hui une solution on est dans
un système on peut pas sortir du système
dans un claquement de doigts etc
on a deux voilà il ya des réalités aussi
qui dépasse les réalités françaises dont
on est obligé malgré tout de tenir
compte
qu'on le veuille ou non par contre je
pense qu'on peut dire que c'est pas non
plus un rêve une idée lointaine etc
c'est des choses qui sont déjà en place
il ya 20 ou 25 % en ile-de-france il ya
25 % des exploitants qui ont mis en
place des diversifications à la ferme
donc c'est pas quelque chose dont on
rêve
c'est des choses qui sont déjà en place
et qui sont déjà ou qui sont efficaces
et qu'elles sont efficaces et qui marche
bien et qui permettent mais par contre
c'est des choses qui se font aujourd'hui
parce que les agriculteurs croit en ses
solutions là et ils vont un peu il ya
des aides de la région ile-de-france
mais comparé aux aides pac c'est quand
même assez disproportionnée et donc
qu'ils vont un peu à la force du poignet
c'est des gens qui acceptent et moi j'ai
la plupart des décès rallye avec qui je
parle sur le plateau de saclay
aujourd'hui c'est des gens qui ont fait
ce pas d'aller vers des diversifications
et ben oui effectivement ils sont passés
un nombre d'heures ils ont doublé le
nombre d'heures qui passe par semaine
sur leur exploitation et d sa célébrité
ça diminue et ris mais c'est aussi
confié sur la vie familiale etc mais ils
le font parce qu'ils croient à cette
orientation là etc et qu'ils ont envie
aussi de retrouver vraiment insensé de
retrouver des contacts etc avec
l'ensemble du tissu socio-économique
avec lequel ils interagissent sur le
territoire a pour terminer pour conclure
luc miserait la question qu'on se pose
qu'on se posait en début d'émission
c'est faut-il changer de modèle alors
faut-il changer de modèle aux faut-il
adapter le modèle actuel moi il ya un
champ qui est très cher à mon coeur qui
dit du passé faisons table rase
mais ça c'est un chant du 19e siècle
donc je ne crois pas dans ces ruptures
brutales
donc effectivement il faut que ça soit
progressif mais c'est possible mais ça
s'inscrit dans une logique plus générale
quand je disais tout à l'heure c'est la
loi du marché ben oui c'est la loi du
marché
c'est la loi du fonctionnement
économique actuelle qui n'est pas
économique mais qui est financier et
donc après sera dans ce système ça ne
pourra pas changer
voilà donc il faut
venir à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
équilibrée où chacun retrouve toute sa
place
l'agriculture peut être on est en
recherche d'emploi à créer mais il ya si
on adopte d'autres modes mais
effectivement il ya là aussi des sources
d'emplois donc de gens qui vivent
correctement
et puis de quelque chose qui est plus
basé sur la qualité
il a fallu faire du quantitatif
on a fait du quantitatif mais il ya bien
longtemps qu'on aurait pu quand même
revoir la qualité et puis travailler sur
quelque chose qui soit plus à échelle
humaine et donc c'est surtout ça et
après on a des choses à inventer
y compris dans nos villes y compris dans
le développement d'une agriculture de
proximité dans nos villes et là dessus
je vous rejoins bien parce que on voyait
de la route conclusion d'ailleurs vous
oubliez également parlé d'un événement
qui arrive moyens furent enlevées va se
passer très vite là dessus après je
conclurai du coup oui sur la question on
voyait bien la plupart des gens
interrogé aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya
une conscience quand même assez
généralisé dans nos sociétés que
l'agriculture a une place très
importante qu'on a un peu oublié et
qu'il faut remettre l'agriculture dans
une place centrale donc ça voilà je vais
pas revenir je pense qu'on a déjà
développé assez en profondeur cette
cette question justement nous on
organise effectivement le 30 septembre
prochain de la semaine prochaine un
grand événement sur les espaces
agricoles naturelles et forestiers du
plateau de saclay on vient de remporter
avec terry citer l'ensemble des acteurs
du territoire qui ont travaillé sur ces
questions là un programme européen
leader qui financent justement les
actions développement local les actions
de développement territorial notamment
agricoles donc on va présenter ses
financements là on présente aussi le
devenir de la zone naturelle agricole et
forestière du plateau de saclay qui
était prévu par la loi du grand paris
et puis c'est un événement qui a une
dimension a aussi assez convivial au
delà des deux tables rondes que j'ai et
que j'ai présentées qui auront lieu de
17 à 18 heures et de 18 à 19 heures
après il ya un ton beaucoup plus
convivial et justement les agriculteurs
puisque c'est bien eux qui sont au
centre de toute cette histoire là qui
viennent nous présenter les produits
qu'ils produisent sur le plateau de
saclay avec yum brands a notamment
échangé avec qui on pourra échanger et
ensuite un concert d'un petit groupe du
coin bazar et bémol donc concert en
entrée libre à partir de 20h30
voilà donc voilà pour toute information
n'hésitez pas à aller sur le site ter et
site et vous pourrez retrouver toutes
les informations sur cet événement merci
à tous les deux en tout cas d'avoir
participé à ce débat très passionnant on
a appris beaucoup de choses n'hésitez
pas à vous de votre côté à réagir sur le
twitter de l'émission hashtag 17,8
société on se retrouve dans deux
semaines pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8
sociétés
bonne soirée